It can swallow entire Gazelles turtles and
even lions. This is the Nile crocodile,
the most dangerous crocodile in the world.
It normally preys on animals found in Africa,
but now it's coming for you.
How easy would it be for this crocodile to swallow you?
What secrets lie in the crocodile stomach and
how would its heart help digest you?
This is what F and here's what would happen if you were swallowed
by a crocodile. If you think something like this is impossible.
Think again, crocodile attacks are more common than shark attacks,
and these attacks are responsible for nearly 1000 fatalities
a year.
So what would happen if you were one of these attacks,
would you be able to survive first?
Let's get to know a little bit more about this creature who's coming after you.
The Nile crocodile is typically found in Africa,
but has also been seen in Florida in the United States.
These crocodiles are incredibly aggressive and are responsible for over
300 attacks on people every year.
What might make it so aggressive is its size.
The Nile crocodile can grow up to six meters long and weigh up to
550 kilograms.
All this combined makes it the most dangerous crocodile on earth.
And now it's coming to swallow you whole
you'd first get attacked by the crocodile somewhere along a river.
And it's likely this would happen between December and may.
Since that's the crocodile's breeding season. As you're walking along the river,
the crocodile would stock you waiting for the perfect opportunity to
attack. You probably wouldn't even notice the crock.
And even if you did, it might be hard to get away from it.
As the Nial crock can run up to 18 kilometers per hour on land.
And as it caught up to you, it would strike it.
Your leg with its massive jaw,
applying 3,500 kilograms of pressure.
This would break your leg, preventing you from getting away.
And now the crocodile could drag you into the river where it likes to
do the rest of its eating.
Now that you're in the water with the crocodile biting into your leg,
it would begin to roll you around the water.
This is it attempting to disorient and drown you.
And at this point you'd be passed out. And now that you're not moving,
the Nile croc would swallow your body. Whole,
you would pass through the crocodiles esophagus and into its stomach.
But wait.
This is a lot of food and not every animal would be able to eat something like
this. So how can the crocodile, well,
the crocodile's stomach is unique.
That's because these creatures swallow rocks to help break up their food.
And that's why the crocodile didn't need to chew you while you're inside the
crocodile stomach. You'd be slushed by all these rocks.
And with that,
your body would be broken up into smaller chunks and rocks.
Aren't the only thing that would help the crock digest you inside the
crocodiles. Body is a heart valve that they control with their nerves.
Instead of this valve, going to the crocodiles lungs, it goes to the stomach.
This allows the crocodile to produce 10 times more gastric acid
and most other animals over the course of a week,
your body would be getting crushed up by all these rocks.
And you'd be getting dissolved by all the stomach acid, skin,
bones, hair, and all.
Then the crocodile would poop out your remains and go hunting for its
next victim.
So the next time your nearest swampy river watch out for crocodiles.
If you're not careful, they can be pretty dangerous,
but you know,
what's even more dangerous than a Nile crocodile terror Crocs,
but we'll leave that.
Story for another. What if.